what's going on guys this is Rob and
first things first I apologize if I
sound a little nasally but I'm getting
over a cold right now so I've taken all
kinds of alka-seltzer and I'm trying to
beat it out of me but the videos have to
be made so so what I wanted to do here
is I wanted to have a conversation about
Spider Man one more day then what I'm
hoping is that by the end of this video
you'll have an understanding of why this
story is largely considered to be one of
the most controversial spider-man
stories ever told the so spider-man one
more day was a four-part miniseries in
2007 that was written by J michael
Straczynski and Joe Quesada with input
from some of Marvel's top writers
including Brian Michael Bendis Mark
Millar Jeph Loeb and Ed Brubaker
now while spider-man one more day can be
considered self-contained the full arc
actually starts immediately after Civil
War with the spider-man back in black
event taking place an amazing spider-man
issues number 538 through 545
sensational spider-man issues 33 through
40 and friendly neighborhood spider-man
issue 17 through 23 all of which lead
directly into the one more day event
proper now prior to the release of one
more day editor-in-chief Joe Quesada had
stated in a 2009 interview with comic
book resources that he believed the
Marvel Universe had fallen into a
position of stagnation something he
vehemently disagreed with and so once he
was placed in the position of
editor-in-chief he sought out to
accomplish three main goals the first
goal was to eliminate the vast number of
mutants which resulted in the House of M
event the second goal was to make the
Marvel Universe as unpredictable as it
had been in the 1960s which resulted in
a civil war event and the third goal was
to return spider-man back to his roots
as being a single male now regarding
this third goal the Joe Quezada had felt
that the marriage between Peter Parker
and Mary Jane could only produce so many
viable stories before began to run its
course before it began to run stale and
that in order for Marvel to be able to
effectively produce vitamins stories for
the next 20 to 30 years the marriage
between Peter and Mary Jane would have
to
then ended at some point in time now
this is a concept that sounds familiar
to you it may be because this is the
exact same stamps that was taken by
Gerry Conway during the death of wind
Stacy but regardless to accomplish this
final goal Joe Quesada orchestrated the
one more day event which centered on two
main ideas the first was the retcon of
the marriage between Peter Parker and
Mary Jane Watson and the second was the
direct fallout from Peter Parker's
public reveal of his identity as
spider-man during the civil war conflict
so during the spider-man back in black
event the kingpin of crime-- Wilson Fisk
after learning that Peter Parker is
spider-man orchestrates a hit on him and
while spider-man is able to pull both
Mary Jane Watson and himself out of the
path of the bullet Aunt May's actually
shot instead now where other elements of
back in black deal with spider-man's
pursuit of the kingpin the most
important part of this story as it
pertains to one more day is how
spider-man deals with Aunt May being
shot because this directly influences
the events of one more day itself in
sensational spider-man number 40 the
final issue of the back in Black Series
and Peter received a visit from the one
above all the absolute power within the
Marvel multiverse now while it's unknown
why the one above all chose to visit
Peter where Marvel gives us is this
insight into the mind of Peter Parker
himself due to having suffered the loss
of Uncle Ben Gwen Stacy Harry Osborn and
facing the possible loss of on May Peter
perceives his life to be a cascade of
failures moreover during his
conversation with the one above all
Peter states that he would be willing to
give up anything to keep on Mae alive
even going so far as having his entire
life rewritten so that he never becomes
spider-man in the first place now in
response to this the one above all shows
Peter the thousands of people whose
lives he's saved during his time as
spider-man but because these individuals
are in fact only people that Peter
Parker had rescued and because he has no
real connection to them the message from
the one above all about the value of the
lives of Peter saved is effectively lost
and so ultimately the journey between
the two of them culminates in Peter
simply just outright asking the one
above all if it's possible for aught
mate to be kept alive at which point be
one of them all replies that everyone
has a role to play and that while it may
be unfair that this is the role of Peter
Parker to lose his uncle to lose several
friends to lose Gwen Stacy and now
possibly lose his on may and so these
feelings of emptiness that immersed
Peter Parker or would actually lead him
into his decision-making process with
the one more day event itself now having
said all that as we get into one more
day what we find here is that Aunt May
is still hospitalized and that she's
actually in a coma and so because Peter
Archer and Mary Jane are unable to cover
the cost of Aunt May's medical bills
Peter turns to Tony Stark
however because Peter had heard against
Tony during the Civil War conflict the
his arrival of stark tower is
immediately met with hostility but after
a brief skirmish Peters able to subdue
Tony Stark and what Peter tells us is
that because Tony had convinced Peter to
reveal his identity publicly that the
current state of Aunt May is Tony's
fault and so as a result Peter demands
that Tony cover the cost of Aunt May's
medical bills to maintain her stay in
the hospital however until he declares
that nothing of the sort is going to
happen and that even if he wanted to
help involving himself with Peter Parker
who's now considered to be a fugitive
would go against Tony's current stance
on registration and so as a result the
Tony allows Peter to escape but after
mulling things over for a little bit
Tony Stark actually changes his mind and
what he does is he sends Jarvis to the
hospital under a false name and actually
pays the hospital two million dollars to
ensure the care of Aunt May now
following this things take a turn and
that to hear critics and fans tell it
this story takes a tumble down the
metaphorical rabbit hole
once on may stay at the hospital is
secured Peter and Mary Jane are informed
that the only thing keeping on may alive
is the life-support system and that
they're basically informed that there's
nothing that can be done for her
so seeking out the assistance of dr.
strange being reviewed in the process
Peter eventually comes across a little
redheaded girl now while this little
girl is ambiguous in that she provides
no information regarding her name or
where her parents are what she does tell
Peter is that she can help him save Aunt
May and so following this little girl
and actually losing her down an alleyway
the Peters taken on the strange journey
where he meets a video game developer
and in what seems to be an attempt at a
philosophical discussion the developer
tells Peter that the reason people love
reading books pertaining to superheroes
and playing video games involving
superheroes is because they can't be a
superhero themselves and by extension
they have no real impact on the world
around them in video games and books
however they control everything they can
fight crime as a hero or they can become
the villain then while this dialogue is
a little sloppy and a little clumsy what
Marvel appears to be doing here is
giving us a reflection of Peters
inability to cope with the randomness of
life and the events that happen but that
despite life's insanity and Peter has
great power and that because of this he
should be grateful rather than asking
for things to change
now following Peters encounter with this
man we find the Peter meets a second man
now the second man makes his appearance
known and by informing Peter that he
believes he knows what a little girl had
gone to but after catching a ride the
older man explains to Peter that he had
been a school nerd and that while the
jocks got the girls and the glory that
he was picked on all the time however he
eventually became an inventor creating
all kinds of devices and gadget read
leading to him becoming extremely
wealthy and employing the various high
school jocks and bullies as janitors and
the light now while Peter initially
congratulate him on getting everything
he ever wanted the older man simply
replies by saying that the one thing he
didn't get was a girl he knew in high
school now at this point the journey
between Peter Parker in the second man's
actually comes to an end and Peter
simply just dropped off in an alleyway
where he's directed to find the young
girl to find a little red
but on his way he comes across the third
and final person who's actually revealed
to be an attractive older woman now as a
truth to begin to talk she reveals that
the video game developer Peter met was
an alternate reality version of himself
and that in this reality appears anger
over never receiving attention from
women and the constant bullying led him
to turn his anger inward the causing him
to isolate himself from people and
becoming immersed in video games because
it was the one element of his life that
he could control what she also explains
here is that the older man is a version
of Peter from a different reality as
well and that in its reality rather than
directing his frustration inward he
directs it outward in attempting to
prove that he has value and so becoming
a tinkerer and a designer of gadgets
this version of Peter Parker eventually
develops Parker Industries which seems
to be a replacement for Stark Industries
in that alternate reality and while his
skills and technology garnered him a
great amount of wealth that his life was
ultimately hollow because the driving
force behind his existence was to simply
prove other people wrong now the reason
for Peter being shown these various
versions of himself is revealed when the
woman eventually casts off her disguise
revealing herself to be the demon
Mephisto the ruler of hell in the Marvel
Universe
now while Mephisto informs Peter that he
has the power to save Aunt May the power
to do this where the ability for
Mephisto to do this requires that heater
make a bargain with him now historically
Mephisto spark is with mortals always
involved but Fisto taking the souls of
the mortals themselves and so what Peter
says is that before he can do or make
any decision about this that he first
needs to talk to Mary Jane and so at
this point Peters actually taken to
where Mary Jane is located where it's
revealed that Mephisto has been having
this exact same conversation with her
and like Peter
Mary Jane says she can't make this
decision without talking to Peter Parker
first now while the two are initially
hesitant but both desire to save Aunt
May they asked what the terms of the
bargain with Mephisto are which is
revealed to be the sacrifice of the
marriage between both Mary Jane and
Peter what Mephisto tells us is that the
love between Mary Jane appear is beyond
compare then that only this will satisfy
as payment for saving the life of Aunt
May
the reason for this is because Mephisto
himself admits that he thrives on the
suffering of mortals and that what will
happen here is that while the marriage
will be Noah Wyle it will be as though
they never were married they had never
become a romantic couple that a fraction
of their soul some part of their soul
will remember what this life is we'll
remember the fact that they were
actually married before things changed
and that the suffering that will stem
from this is something Mephisto can
quite literally feast on and so what
happens here is that Peter Parker and
Mary Jane eventually give in and they
simply sacrifice their marriage to
Mephisto and so what this does is it
changes the timestream in its entirety
but furthermore what Mephisto reveals is
that the little girl who had initially
appeared to Peter Parker was actually
their daughter and that this future
version of their child will actually
never exist because instead of keeping
themselves married they've chosen to
save on May and so by virtue of never
having been married this child will
never exist and so what this does is
this result in Peter Parker waking up
the next day and having no recollection
of ever having been married to Mary Jane
Watson
the so following the release of one more
day the story was met with universally
negative reactions from almost all media
outlets and fans and truth the kind of
backlash received from this story hadn't
been seen since the death of Gwen Stacy
and actually led to writer J michael
Straczynski distancing himself from the
project the reason for this was because
many fans had felt that where the death
of when Stacey taught spider-man the
difference between acting like a hero
and being the hero the marriage of
Pierre and Mary Jane was one of the
longest-running romances in comics and
the ending of their marriage had no
viable effect on spider-man in terms of
character growth moreover while Mary
Jane was initially hated following the
death of when Stacy the spider-man fans
had grown to love her character and the
element of Peters marriage to her and to
see it all come crumbling down due to
editorial concern of story viability was
a shot to the gut of many spider-man
fans now where Marvel didn't initially
tell us how it was a Mephisto had a
limited to the marriage of Mary Jane
Watson to Peter Parker in 2010 Joe
Cassano releases story called one moment
in time where it was revealed that
Mephisto had changed the past so that
Eddie Brock had escaped police custody
as a result
Peter sought out Eddie Brock and during
the conflict was knocked unconscious
causing him to miss his wedding with
Mary Jane now in addition to the retcon
of peter's marriage to Mary Jane Watson
Marvel also changed the status quo of
both the spider-man
stories and the spider-man publications
firstly Harry Osborn who had previously
died in a botched attempt to kill Mary
Jane and Peter Parker was brought back
from the dead and revealed to have
actually been in Europe and in addition
to this the sensational spider-man and
friendly neighborhood spider-man titles
were cancelled and Marvel effectively
rebooted the amazing spider-man
publications in their entirety in order
to basically start spider-man off with
brand new day
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later peace
you